all right in other news now Israel has
deported a Palestinian French human
rights lawyer and activist after his
Jerusalem residency rights were revoked
earlier this month Salah hamuri had been
detained without charge since March
under so-called administrative detention
Israeli authorities have imprisoned him
several times alleging his involvement
in an assassination plot of a former
Chief Rabbi he was also branded a
terrorist by Israel as a member of the
popular front for the liberation of
Palestine Rob McBride is following
developments for us from West Jerusalem
hello there Rob what more can you tell
us about this deportation
yeah the interior ministry here uh
confirmed that tamori was put on a plane
early Thursday morning Bound for Paris
uh so bringing to an end his long fight
against deportation he is a a
Palestinian French human rights lawyer
also activist but according to the
Israelis he is a terrorist they say he's
been involved with a terrorist
organization uh that he has served
several times in prison his longest uh
prison stretch was seven years and that
was after a plea agreement in the
alleged plot to assassinate a former
Chief Rabbi and also a spiritual leader
here now after he was released from that
sentence the according to the
authorities he was still involved in
what they say were terrorist activities
they revoked his Jerusalem residency
it's this residency status that
Palestinians in the occupied East
Jerusalem live under and once that was
revoked because he is a dual National
with French citizenship it then opened
the way for him to be deported to France
but he has never spent any length of
time in France although he has a French
wife and his children who are in France
themselves
Jerusalem has always been his home so it
has raised serious concerns from human
rights groups here that the authorities
could use this to Target other activists
it's also raise concerns in France
itself and Rob just briefly what is the
what do they mean when they say that
they've put him in administrative
detention
yeah this has highlighted this very
controversial practice whereby somebody
can be detained for months at a time and
then you can get an extension to that
where they don't charge you with
anything and they don't even tell you
what you are being held under according
to the authorities this is so that they
can protect sensitive intelligence which
might lead to other attacks but
according to opponents of this it's
simply being used by the authorities to
lock up people that they don't like and
it is at the moment there are more than
800 Palestinians being held under this
controversial administrative detention
in Israeli prisons
all right we appreciate it thank you
very much Rob McBride live for us there
in West Jerusalem